here with more in a very first interview
since her son took the stand wendy
rittenhouse is with us um
i'm sure this is a hard time for you and
your family
uh i want to take
this audience back to yesterday when
your son was testifying and he had a
tough time let me play this
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
there were
people right there
what
a pretty good re i read people pretty
well i've done it my whole life
and that seemed like a classic panic
attack that we were witnessing on the
stand
that's your son
how did that make you feel
it just
i just broke down with
with kyle crying like that
it made me feel
heartbroken sad
and i wanted to just go up there and
just hug him and tell him it would be
okay
when the then candidate now president of
the united states
and other elected officials
that don't know anything about your son
refer to him as a white supremacist
i have yet to see any evidence
whatsoever
that he is such a person
and when prominent people say that
what did that how did that impact you
and how did it impact him
when i saw what um
afterwards of the
president kennedy
candidate
debate when i saw that
i wasn't shocked
i was angry
president biden don't know my son
whatsoever and
he's not a white supremacist he's not a
racist
and
he did that
for the votes
and
i was so angry
for a while at him
and what he did to my
son he defamed him
let's go back to that night and let's
roll this videotape this was put
together by
your former your son's former attorney
lynn wood
and you see your son running and you see
a crowd of people
racing to catch up to him
the first person knocks off his hat then
he's down on the ground then we've got
this picture
of
an individual with his leg up about to
pound his leg into his face into the
cement that was one of the shootings
what do you see there
i see this man
trying to kick my son in the face
i was scared i was frightened
i thought my son was going to die that
night
when
you
when you when you see the tape and
you've heard witnesses testify that he
was trying to de-escalate the situation
there when you look at the tape when you
look at the witness testimony
and then the prosecution brings on their
star witness who got shot by your son
and that star witness admitted on the
stand under oath
that he aimed a loaded gun at your son
before your son shot him that would seem
to me a classic case of self-defense
your thoughts
when i look at the video with
that guy
pointing a gun
to my son's head
i thought
he was going to die
this guy
just
put
pointed his gun at his head
and i
it took a long time to
just
just to grasp on
that he was alive
and
knowing that he's with me
i'm
i'm
i'm grateful
and
i'm
relieved that he's okay
but
he has
a lot of healing to do
because he does have nightmares
for
from this
let me let me ask you about the judge
who has been extraordinarily harsh
against the prosecution that they're
right on the border line they may be
over the border line it better stop i
was astonished when you began your
examination by commenting on post-arrest
silence it has been basically on this
country for 40 50 years i have no idea
why you would do something like that
don't get brazen with me you knew very
well attorneys can't go into these types
of areas do you think your son has
received a fair trial
the judge is very fair
people that i talk to that lives in
kenosha
all their lives
they told me that judge schroeder is a
very fair drudge and he doesn't allow no
nonsense
in his courtroom
nobody ever knows what a jury's going to
do
i'm not asking you specifically for
their reactions but as you on a scale of
one to ten how seriously
do you believe they're taking this case
because they hold your son's life in
their hands
yeah they do
and with the jury they've been
keeping a close eye on every evidence
every testimony
and they're paying good tension what's
been said
that's the truth
let me ask you this last question i know
your son was a lifeguard i know your
son's stated reason for going there was
to help protect stores and
and and help on the medical front
um
have you and your son discussed
whether or not if he had to do it over
again he would go into a situation like
that
with
kyle i know him and he probably would do
it again because that's the type of
person he is
he always wants to help people even
since he was a little boy that's all he
wanted to do was help people it doesn't
matter if it was breaking leaves for the
neighbors
talking to them
or just
being goofy
yeah
that's how
i raised him is to help people
wendy i can't i've learned in 33 years
of broadcasting not to predict a jury
outcome um
but i will tell you i think the
prosecution has put on a horrific case
thank you for being with us and uh
our thoughts and prayers with you and
your family